thank you for joining us we begin this
NewsHour with some breaking news from
Ukraine and we are getting reports of
multiple blasts across the capital the
mayor of key says air defenses in the
region are engaging targets let's go
straight to Charles Stratford who's in
key Force Charlie tell us about what's
been happening in the lifestyle
well fully it was about an hour ago
where the first explosions were heard we
were in the center of Kiev actually in a
in a shopping area and what sounded like
a very large explosion and then air
defense systems uh going into action we
understand according to Mayor Klitschko
that there have been 10 explosions in
this latest attack we cannot confirm
whether these explosions were places
taking direct hits or whether in fact
they were interceptions but we do know
that there has been damage
um there are reports of a hotel that has
been damaged there are also reports of a
radar station in the city that has been
damaged and there are now reports of
casualties mayor Klitschko saying that
uh one elderly woman and one elderly man
have died in the capital city and there
are at least four people injured in the
region of kirmanitsky which was another
that area that was hit now that's to the
wet in the west of the country there are
also reports of
um explosions in Mikko life in the south
of the country now of course these
strikes what's arguably quite unusual
about them is
um that they're happening at this time
of day by and large the majority of the
so-called Kamikaze drone and cruise
missile attacks happen very early in the
morning
um this was yeah sort of two o'clock in
the afternoon quite surreal scenes on
the streets though no real sense of
panic the area we were there were a lot
of shoppers out obviously it's New
Year's Eve we were in a kind of a market
area people were very controlled
obviously anxious but it seems so
certainly there's all the last half an
hour or so in this area that things have
calmed down we haven't heard any more
explosions but of course it comes on the
back this is the third consecutive day
around about 70 Cruise Miss missiles
that were launched at Targets across the
country on Friday the majority of those
were intercepted and then yesterday
there were according to the government
16 Kamikaze drone attacks as well
um which were all intercepted here in
Kiev and zaparisia and dinipro petrovsk
so yeah a very worrying scenario here as
we go into the new year we are now going
to get down into some of these areas
where we hear some of these buildings
have been damaged and we'll obviously be
bringing you updates in the hours ahead
Charlie thank you very much for the
moment we will be checking in with you
of course later for more on the
situation in Ukraine's Capital Kiev